[Musik]
gahma job meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen die heute zu einer
neuen episode minecraft mit luca staffel
2 hier sind wir in der letzten episode
stehen geblieben und haben die hobbit
höhle leider nicht wirklich fertig
stellen können weil uns noch eine menge
gegenstände fehlen gerade hier für die
küche hier bücherregal dafür brauchen
wir nämlich leder und auch hier in dem
lagerraum fielen uns auch noch die ein
oder andere materialien deswegen werden
wir uns nun erstmal heute ich weiß es
macht jetzt vielleicht keinen sinn weil
man sich denkt ja du brauchst
materialien warum gehst dann in eine
höhle allerdings brauche ich neben
materialien natürlich auch erstmal ein
bisschen sachen um mir hier irgendwie
eine bessere rüstung macht und ich habe
auch bock paar diamanten zu finden
deswegen ganz fix it times wie ich mich
auf eine höhle expedition vorbereitet
so meine lieben freunde ich habe ich
jetzt gerade einmal fertig vorbereitet
hier vorne unsere hop und hüllt sich auf
jeden fall sehr sehr sehr sehr wild aus
ich habe bock da oben dann vielleicht
einen stall drauf zu machen mit ein
bisschen kühl oder so vielleicht jetzt
allerdings auch ein bisschen zu laut wir
müssen mal schauen die sache ist
allerdings dass wir ja hier vorne neben
unserer hobbit hürde genau hier war es
noch eine kleine höhle haben wo wir
bisher nur grob reingeguckt haben und da
haben wir ja bereits entdeckt als ich
mich hier so ein bisschen unter tage
gebilde begeben habe dass wir oben
rechts in der minimap gesehen haben dass
wir hier tatsächlich so ein kleines
system haben von daher
habe ich mich vorbereitet
einige neue gegenstand auch mitgenommen
die wir benötigen könnten und jetzt
geht's los mit der ersten richtigen
höhlen expedition von minecraft
direkt wasser schaut euch das nach oben
rechts an
was ist denn das für ein riesiges
höhlensystem also ich bin wirklich
gespannt was uns hier erwarten wir
[Musik]
können jetzt mit dem aufnehmen
ich will zuerst mal nicht riskieren und
lassen sie mal hier durchgehend der haut
auch direkt ab ich brauche hier erst mal
ganz kurz die cola ab und dann auch hier
vorne das eisen und dass wir uns nun
weiter hier runter bewegen können ich
habe keine ahnung funktionen gleich auf
das nächste mal verraten
wir haben hier auf jeden fall eine baby
am start hier mal direkt eine fackel hin
seit 4
ali
[Musik]
kur und noch
ihr habt schon gesehen ich habe mir
[Musik]
direkt weiter ich habe mir einen bogen
gekostet in der time labs weil ich ein
paar pfeile haben und auch wenn ich hier
das ein oder andere skelett töten werde
werde ich auf jeden fall auch pfeile
bekommen um mich hier weiter fort zu
bauen und es ist gerade 34
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gerade wenn man irgendwie auf distanz
kämpfe gehen wird will ich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bin irgendwie noch zu sehr gewöhnt dass
wir wie in minecraft mit luca staffel
eins extrem gut aus bei vorbereitet
waren und dementsprechend
uns nie gedanken machen muss nun
irgendwelche monster ich brauche hier
alles mal so ein bisschen schöner dass
wir hier auch nachher entspannt
hochgehen können so sollte das ganze
hier auf jeden fall ein guter weg sein
so dass wir jetzt hier erst mal alles so
ein bisschen versuchen können
auszuleuchten ich setze einfach mal ich
hab gar nicht mehr die fackel noch der 2
beziehungsweise in meiner hand soll hier
einmal fackeln hin hier vorne jetzt
einmal ganz kurz schnell durch waschen
so dass wir einmal zumindest dem bereich
ausgeleuchtet haben und wissen woran wir
sind es geht halt in tausende richtungen
hier hier und jetzt auch noch weiter die
links geht's weiter hier ist allerdings
auch niemand da unten ist niemand es ist
sehr sehr verwinkelt hier fordern wir
wieder diese komischen leuchte rannten
und ich muss mich allerdings erstmal
darauf konzentrieren wir hier vorne
vielleicht ein bisschen wasser
mitzunehmen fall zu viel aber entdecken
sollten
[Musik]
es ist stressig aber ich bin ganz
ehrlich mein ziel für heute sind
diamanten und jetzt auf jeden fall
weiter freunde hier sind spinnen weben
und auch zäune
das heißt wir haben hier unten
unser gang system ich bin hier einfach
jetzt mal runter gegangen als wäre es
das selbstverständlichste der welt
allerdings muss ich wirklich an jeder
ecke hier ist beleuchtet
und hier komme ich ich muss hier
wirklich an jeder ecke aufpassen ich
konzentriere mich jetzt erst mal nicht
zurück
ich konzentriere mich jetzt erst mal
nicht so krass auf kohle oder auf reisen
davon haben wir zu hause
hat sind grabl wie wieder ich würde
sagen davon haben wir auf jeden fall zu
hause erstmal genug die sache ist dass
ich wirklich auf die suche gehen möchte
nach diamanten redstone und lapislazuli
hirnwasser einmal nämlich auch noch mal
ganz kurz mit jetzt gehen wir in diese
richtung hier einfach mal weiter nach
oben waren wir von da sind wir auch
gekommen und schaut
[Musik]
am giftspinnen
habe wieder gift ich bin hier fertig als
da ich habe dreieinhalb herzen wir bauen
jetzt einfach mal hier vorne die
seitenteile ab um dann schlussendlich
auch den spanner hier abzubauen wir
können auf jeden fall keine spinnen
spawnen ich nehme an eisen schwerte
noch eine a o mein gott das ist ja
vorstellen dass ein spieler vor
ein herz
ich war kurz auf einem herz in der zeit
wo ich mich gerade so ein bisschen
generiert habe habe ich hier vorne jetzt
auch ein bisschen kohle abgebaut ihr
habt doch gerade wahrscheinlich gesehen
dass ich nicht alles mitgenommen habe
die sache jetzt nämlich wir haben
wirklich genug kohle und ich möchte mich
eher auf wertvolle gegenstände
orientieren beziehungsweise
konzentrieren hier vorne das kupfer
nämlich jetzt einfach auch mal mit ich
habe immer noch keinen richtigen plan
was ich mit kupfer machen soll
allerdings gehen wir erstmal weiter in
diese richtung hier das ist ist
auch das schwebt hier in der luft
ok
haben auf jeden fall hier vorne holz auf
dem boden und sagen wir haben die kiste
wir haben die kiste freuen und wir haben
darin keine diamanten allerdings
lapislazuli kürbiskerne benötigen wir
nicht die fackel nehme ich einfach mal
mit man kann man nie genug haben
goldener apfel und die goldbarren die
schienen benötige ich auch erstmal noch
nicht ich weiß nicht was ich mit sheen
machen sollte an diesem projekt ob ich
irgendwas verbinden möchte ich hab's ja
auch überlegt mit der porte modifikation
so ein bisschen zu machen dass ich von a
nach b gut reisen kann die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mit minecraft forge
spiele und für die pforte animation
modifikation benötigt man halt leider
jetzt habe ich leider kein einmal mehr
für die lava ist aber auch egal die
sache ist dass man dafür die fabric
modifikation benötigt und ich weiß nicht
wie ich fabric zusammen mit forge mache
also es ist jetzt natürlich sehr sehr
krasser nerd hier beim thema minecraft
aber wenn irgend jemand von euch mir
weiterhelfen kann und sagen kann wie ich
das eventuell kombinieren kann also dass
sich die pforte modifikation zocken kann
unter minecraft fort dann schreibt mir
gerne und in die kommentare generell
könnt ihr auch mal gerne die video
beschreibung schauen dort findet ihr
nämlich einmal alle modifikationen
eingeblendet die ich nutze in minecraft
mit luca staffel 2 hier das haben mich
über das projekt hinweg bisher viele
leute bisher schon gefragt luca was ist
das für eine modifikation wodurch die
ganzen tiere bekommst was sind das für
biome was ist es was ist das was ist das
texture pack ich hab ich das einfach mal
alles in die beschreibung unten gepackt
dann könnt ihr euch das mal was hab ich
denn jetzt
leuchten beutel okay
diese höhle nimmt auch kein ende perfekt
ist das android vorhin sagen ihr könnt
generell gern mal und in der
beschreibung vorbeischauen wenn ihr euch
einerseits für die mods interessiert
dich benutzer allerdings andererseits
auch für das setup in dem ich hier
generell aufnehmen also was habe ich für
ein mikro was habe ich für bildschirme
für mikrofon habe meine kamera das habe
ich euch auch endlich mal und in die
beschreibung gepackt habe das eine
zeitlang ausgelöscht über ein paar
monate hinweg weil ich mir dachte sind
christian allerdings kamen jetzt so
viele fragen dass ich mir gedacht habe
bevor ich da in dem video so richtig
darauf eingehe zeige ich euch das
einfach und in der beschreibung hier
vorne war ich schon das war hier der
raum wo ich schon gesagt habe okay haben
wir ein bisschen holz das heißt wir
gehen jetzt erst mal diese richtung wir
haben schon länger keine monster mehr
gefunden was allerdings auch ein gutes
zeichen ist
jetzt nicht so dass ich jetzt scharf
darauf bin monster zu finden hier vorne
können wir auf jeden fall langen laufen
hier geht hier geht's nach draußen
was
es nicht war oder ich habe ich bin jetzt
so weit nach oben gelaufen dass ich hier
fast wieder draußen mit oder hat
[Applaus]
perfekt ich gebe da rein ich bin dann
auf jeden fall so lange durch die höhle
gelaufen habe erz abgebaut bis ich
folgendes gefunden habe
[Musik]
kann er hier hoch
ich dachte das wäre so ein kleines
krabbel ding gewesen
ich wusste ich dass das hier so ein
kaninchen ist
also ergreift wenig an
ich will allerdings trotzdem gern wissen
was hier bei dem abgeht
okay der macht nichts
drop da irgendwas
auch nicht ich hab dann auf jeden fall
weiter meine hülle erkundet erz abgebaut
und hat sich dann in eine wand eingebaut
habe weil ich dachte dass sich aufgrund
der vielen geräusche dahinter ins bonner
befinden wird sich folgendes entdeckt
[Musik]
ich höre hier irgendwie geräusche
und habe auch oben rechts auf der
minimap gesehen
er lag ein scheiß
ja aber kein scheiß
aber kein scheiß
ich weiß nicht warum bin
[Musik]
das kannst du dir nicht aus sagt ne
ich sag's wie sizzla das liegt alles an
diesem leisten vintage wetter den ich
gehabt und an dem huder da hinten hängen
die beide am ersten 12 18 uhr kommen in
denen gewisse leute
[Musik]
trinken hier
er kommt ja nicht hoch oder er kommt
sich nicht hoch
[Musik]
und leute und remix 42
ich habe hier gerade
in end raum entdeckt
meine lieben freunde
ich muss einfach
in der letzten folge eigentlich hierhin
und läutet wächst hier
warum war das klar ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich dachte eigentlich schreibe
entspannten titel mensch erste höhen
expedition wächst hier
beim exeo und leute 2 max hier
[Musik]
nicht mehr ausdenken was das für ein
scheiß projekt hier ist mein einziger
plan war es dem heutigen video entspannt
die erste höhlen expedition zu starten
vielleicht das ein oder andere seltene
erde zu finden was wir auch geschafft
haben und dann vielleicht auch den einen
oder anderen diamanten zu finden war ich
ja sogar noch gar nicht die höhle ist
riesig die hülle ist sehr sehr riesig
ich weiß ich sage das gefühlt über jede
höhle allerdings ist diese höhle hier
wirklich enorm riesig ich weiß auch dass
ich hier vorne runter gegangen bin hier
um die ecke dann war hier links der
etwas größere raum wo wir allerdings
nicht den weg lang gelaufen sind sondern
hier dann hier runter und ab jetzt
habe ich wirklich keinen plan mehr
russland ging
ich hoffe einfach nur so sehr dass ich
ohne und da sind wir auch schon
angekommen einer lieben freunde also
hier sind noch alle meine items mal
schauen ob hier noch irgendwie passt
weil jetzt muss ich auf jeden fall alles
erstmal einsammeln bevor ihr wieder
irgendwie ankommt denn dann könnten
diese sache nie direkt weiter in die
luft fliegen es scheint allerdings so
als ob alles noch da wäre und ich werde
jetzt auch mal kurz zuvor gehen dass ich
mir alle ärzte kurz hier in blöcke
verwandelt dass ich ein bisschen mehr
platz sparen kann und hier unten
schmeiße ich jetzt auch erstmal die
dinge ein die ich nicht benötige
beispielsweise noch so die anderen
bruchsteine und so ein bisschen
verrottetes fleisch so dass ich hier
vorne zum anschauen kann was ich hier
für blöcke habe die pfeile benötige ich
auf jeden fall
theorie die jetzt nicht unbedingt
allerdings habe ich das wichtigste auf
jeden fall erstmal hier am start und
rafting table werde ich jetzt auch mal
ganz kurz mit nehme ich habe meine
rüstung und jetzt werde ich mir auch
direkt bisschen rutschig
war schon krass ähnliche
gold und ofenkartoffeln ist aber auch
egal schnell der ofen kartoffel die
reinhauen meine lieben freunde ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht ob ich hier
vorn in die kiste geschaut habe wir
haben hier nur eisen drin die äpfel
benötige ich nicht ich weiß nicht was
ich mit der information jetzt anfangen
soll das hier unten dass stronghold ist
es ist natürlich sehr geil allerdings
bringt es mich gerade überhaupt nicht
weiter es ist cool zu wissen dass direkt
unter dem ort wo ich mich quasi
niedergelassen habe völlig unwissend
dass hier unten in stronghold ist ist
natürlich sehr geil dass ich weiß dass
es hier unten ist die sache ist aber
wirklich das bringt mir absolut
garnichts aktuell es bringt mir nichts
in die richtung dass ich weiß wo guck
mal hier können wir uns jetzt immerhin
bewegen für diese und das nie kriegen
wir auch nicht sind die richtungen zu
wissen nicht wie oft ich an zeit im
kreis
ich gehe mal ganz kurz wieder hoch in
eine höhere ein umbau auch hier vorne
alles kurz mal so ein bisschen wieder zu
so dass es zumindest ein bisschen so
aussieht als wenn hier nie was passiert
wäre ich hätte niemals gedacht dass
unsere ganz normale erste höhlen
expeditionen hierin endet
sonst rollt ist extrem selten
man braucht eigentlich extrem lange
entfernungen unseren teil zu finden ich
hatte mein freund lukas offline schon
extrem ist gut aber das hier
das ist sich einfach unter
also das ist wirklich brutal ich habe
mir jetzt einfach mal 45 leitern kräfte
mir hier so einen kleinen weg nach oben
zu bauen und da sind wir auch schon hier
oben angekommen meine lieben freunde ich
setze jetzt einfach mal so ein paar
fackeln hier drumrum damit wir halt
wissen dass wir hier vorne runter
gegangen sind in unsere höhle mehr
fackeln habe ich sogar gerade nicht am
start sollte allerdings klar erkennbar
sein da vorne ist unsere
[Musik]
sorry aber
das kannst du dir wirklich nicht aus
[Musik]
einfach 40 blöcke
neben unserer hobbit höhle befindet sich
das ende
wir müssen hier wirklich den nächst
menge bäume fällen eher dass hier so
viele monster spawnen aber gut meine
lieben freunde ich beende an der stätte
das heutige video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder
mit lucas staffel 2 was soll ich machen
soll ich wieder runter in die höhle sich
das ende weiter erkunden sollen die
hauptschule weiter bauen so etwas
anderes wollen schreibt ohne die
kommentare ich muss ganz schön werden
bevor er sterbe
[Musik]